i am a proud pet mom and uh major animal
rescue advocate uh so much
so that people call me dr drew little by
the way this cat is so smart i think we
might have to hold him okay
um
peter reports that there are up to 100
million homeless cats living in the u.s
um so we invited animal drew gooders
because we like to pen my name with
everything
who volunteer at various pet shelters
and clinics around new york and new
jersey to share how they're advocating
for animal rights specifically furry
felines so please welcome with me right
now
is judy s kenazi
marissa rizzuto
and joanne monets
first of all
thank you for everything that you do
um i would love to start with you judy
uh you brought the kittens along um from
the grateful paws animal rescue
um how is it working there
so i actually do a lot of independent
rescue grateful paws is actually one of
the organizations that i work with
these kittens the day before hurricane
ida hit someone called me and said hey
the diner down the street has kittens
and a hole in the concrete
so i ran and grabbed them thank god
because you know with the flooding with
ida so it's
blueberry maple and pancake
thank you for thank you running to the
diner playing hurricane ida and being
the human that you are thank you
i
means a lot i mean it's it's rough work
but you know i've been passionate about
it ever since i was younger um my mom
has always been involved with rescue so
um i really appreciate you bringing this
to light and having
people on to kind of shed light onto how
animal rescue
is
it's just it's something very important
to me and marissa your company is called
i love my pet more than you that's funny
i like that bitey piffy funny name
um will you tell us more about your love
of animals as well as fashion sure so um
i always had two passions in life and it
was fashion and animals i was always the
kid like bringing home a stray and
begging my parents to take it but then i
went to fit as well so
um and i was a fashion stylist for about
15 years so
i went through a divorce about several
years ago and while i was kind of going
through the stress of a divorce i kind
of threw myself into animal rescue it
gave me
a purpose it took the stress away so
every weekend
on saturdays i would transport cats and
puppies from all parts of new york and
new jersey to get them to foster homes
or adoptable homes and with that
i decided i wanted to start a brand
something to bring animal awareness
adoption but also for people that are
obsessed with their pets so
i came up with i love my pet more than
you and i kind of threw my fashion
background into it so all of our
products are very fashion-centric pop
culture inspired but they're for animal
rescue and we donate 10 to 25 percent of
our profits to animal rescues and
shelters that is fantastic i love it
and
your organization is called all about
spay and neuter and you've also overcome
major obstacles in order to foster cats
would you tell us about that sure um in
2004 i found it all about spay neuter
and i ran the rescue out of my home
and um
right before hurricane sandy i had about
15 adults and 50 kittens
and i decided to stay home during the
storm
and i was laying in my bed we lost
electricity just making sure everybody
was safe and all sudden i heard a little
water i said oh this is going to be
nothing bad and the next thing i knew
the floorboards exploded and four and a
half feet of water rushed into my home
so my main concern at that point was to
get the cats to safety and the next day
my volunteers and i came and we rented a
small office somewhere just to get the
cats to safety and a year later we
actually bought a storefront building on
marigota massapequa for our adoption
center
even more recently i purchased a 40-foot
spay nudibus
and we presently are doing our own
surgeries with vets that come in and vet
techs that come in and we're doing um we
do like 700 feral cats a year and 200 to
250 kittens a year oh my gosh
that's incredible thank you thank you oh
you guys i can't thank you enough thank
you thank you for bringing us on thank
you thank you so
much
well your
rescue efforts have certainly not gone
unnoticed and our friends
at one of my very favorite companies in
the world world's best cat litter are
donating five thousand dollars to each
of you
um
[Applause]
plus a two year supply of cat litter
in order
to service all the animals thank you so
much thank you and
that's not all they are also donating 5
000 pounds of cat litter to the animal
shelter of your choice
[Applause]
thank you so much to our animal true
gooders
[Music]
you